what it's cold I need the scarf now -
[Applause]
[Music]
well folks if you thought I was done
covering the Deathly Hallows part-2 well
huh when I was a I was commissioned to
do a revisit of these films that did
include the fantastic B's movie so
fantastic beasts and where to find them
this is a little bit odd now because
doing my revisit of the original eight
films in the Harry Potter film series
those who are all actually films that I
didn't have any kind of formal review up
for because the last of those came out
before I started this channel whereas
now I'm actually rearview Inglourious
Lee it was crazy long ago with the worst
Cameron like I'm not sure it's worth
going back and saying but I now have a
direct comparison for what I thought
before at the time and we can see what's
changed now I was very curious to go
back and re-watch this one because I
know of the issues I had at the time
that I said I saw it originally one of
them I softened on significantly and
that is the character of Newt Scamander
himself as a protagonist when I first
saw it I kind of couldn't get over the
fact that Eddie Redmayne just lacked
charisma and was not particularly
magnetic as a presence and that really
kind of threw me off as far as the lead
character goes and so I wasn't
particularly keen on the character of
Newt having sort of lived with the idea
of what he is as a protagonist for a bit
longer and seeing some of the very
well-put-together and wonderful
endorsements of him as a character from
other people I've come to appreciate him
for what he is as opposed for judging
him for what he wasn't which is what I
did the first time that I saw this and
that's reflected my original review so
knowing that I was going to enjoy Newt
much more as a character this time than
I did the first time that I saw it I was
hopeful that other elements that hadn't
worked for me the first time might also
now work better that didn't really end
up being the case I will still say that
I liked it better
now that I did the first time I saw but
that's really only on the strength of me
getting what they're doing with Newt
this time which honestly I just kind of
did it about the only other thing that
was better for me this time than last
time was last time I went to see it it
was at a 3d screening and this is one of
those movies that because of how
visually dark it already is 3d doesn't
know favors because 3d tends to by the
nature of the glasses tends to darken
even even slightly more I had a really
hard time following what the heck was
going on especially during the climax
section of the film so that was better
but that didn't really affect my overall
opinion about what the climax was only
only that I could see it a bit better so
okay let's get into this thing this
thing alright let's start with what's
good before I start getting into my
nitpicks because once they start doing
that they're gonna start as net picks
they're gonna grow and that's gonna
overtake the review let's be realistic
here
so as I said Newt himself I get him now
I get him as a soft-spoken quiet
empathetic character his what makes him
the hero of the story is not that he is
more charismatic that he's a leader that
he is better in action or anything that
it's his capacity for empathy and for
having that kind of protagonist the way
that they designed him wrote him and the
way that Eddie Redmayne place him works
very well he is wonderfully endearing
and you really do feel that awkwardness
but at the same time his passion for
what it is he does especially like when
he gets arrested and it's very likely
that he is going to be sentenced that
maybe he doesn't know it's gonna be that
extreme yet but he knows he's in trouble
the only thing he's yelling out is don't
harm the creatures bade they aren't a
danger to anybody that's where his
concern is that's where his fears cuz
that's what he doesn't get people but he
gets these creatures and he knows other
people don't and he is always pleading
on their behalf
I do enjoy Newt as a character that said
he's still not my favorite character in
the film
Jacob is cuz he's awesome and amazing
and wonderful and sweet and so endearing
and like that when he takes the giga
water in this little I love him he's so
good and I guess in a way I he is
awkward while still being a little bit
charismatic in a little bit magnetic and
I think first time I'd watched it
I had wished that had been the case for
Newt it works better for me now that it
isn't but he is still my favorite
character and the thing I also really
like Queenie in this she is a highlight
for me as well most of the other
supporting actors are fine for what it
is that they're doing but what they're
doing is not excessively interesting to
me by and large talking in broad strokes
but you know Jacob and Queenie are
wonderful I love them as as a couple in
terms of their getting to know each
other and again like Jacob to me steals
every single scene that he is in and
that's even when he has his Cringer
moments because there is a bit of cringe
humor around him but he is so wonderful
and heartwarming for me to watch I roll
with it and I usually can't stand cringe
humor so I think that really speaks to
the strength of how the characters
written and more importantly performed
because he is beautifully perfectly cast
love him to death
the other thing I really like is
basically anything dealing with the
title of the film which is the fantastic
beasts I love the feel of Wonder and
whimsy that is brought about especially
when we see them through the eyes of
both Newt and Jacob in terms of getting
the sense of wonder and magic about them
and that is by far the most fun I love
the knitler the boat Runkle has a
wonderful little bit of attitude to him
even though the ones with less
identifiable personality to them are
still really cool and there is this this
sense of awe around them and it's really
well put together and that for me is
when the movie is at its best which
unfortunately is not all the movie and
is absolutely none of the climax
whatsoever and now we're starting to get
to it so the fundamental problem with
this film at its core is that it tries
to have it both ways in the same film
because if you look back at the Harry
Potter franchise it has a progression it
starts out wonderful and magical and
whimsical and it darkens as it goes but
the thing is that was a seven book eight
movie transition from one to the other
it was done in pieces it was done by
steps and by the time it was dark it had
earned the journey to get there the
problem with this movie fundamentally at
its core is that it tries to bring back
the fun in the magic in the whimsy
through new
and through the magical fantastical
creatures while at the same time having
the overall mood in tone of the friggin
deathly hallows and the two don't mix in
the same film it worked in the original
because we had a steady transition from
one to the other they try and jam both
into the same movie here and basically
what you have is you have something that
for the first two-thirds more or less
for the majority of its runtime feels
like the first two Harry Potter films
and then you have a third act that feels
like the last two Harry Potter films and
that is a jarring gear ship that doesn't
flow well and also it means I don't
exactly know who this is for because if
this was for the audience that was more
invested in the whimsy of the Wizarding
World well then it's gonna lose them in
the climax which is basically what it
did for me that's not to say that I
don't like the darker elements but what
worked for me in the original film
series is that it got it was a journey
to get there didn't just suddenly give
them to me and if people are more
invested in the darker elements and they
and the heavier end of things well
they're gonna feel a little bit dragged
down by the whimsy that keeps jutting in
and is overtaking the first two-thirds
jamming this all into one film was a
really weird decision I think ultimately
that is the choice that hampers the vast
majority of what's going on it kind of
need cats the thing from the word go and
also I think it was I think was a
mistake to retain David Yates I just
think that and it's not that he's a bad
director I liked what he did with the
latter Harry Potter films he directed
from order of the Phoenix all the way
through to Deathly Hallows part-2 so he
did the last four of those which was
find it worked for me there and I'm not
even gonna say he's a bad director in
this what I don't like is it it by
retaining him it makes his visual
approach to this world
the definitive way to depict the
Wizarding World and I don't like that
whoever you think did it best through
the first bundle of directors whether it
was Chris Columbus whether it was
Alfonso Cuaron whether it was Mike
Newell or whether it was David Yates
they each brought a little bit something
different and it gave it a more
full-bodied variant flavor it is now
becoming homogenized by retaining David
Yates again and for a time period that
has nothing to do with
the chunk that he did so now it makes
the Wizarding World of the 19 with teens
20s whatever it is look and feel the
same at the Wizarding World of the 1990s
at the tail end of the Harry Potter
series proper and it shouldn't feel the
same it should feel different whatever
whether you do or don't like say for
instance the Star Wars prequels it is
not a mistake that they look and feel
different from the original Star Trek
Star Wars trilogy which was very cobbled
together because we were dealing with
rebels would scrape together resources
and everything looks like it was held
together with strings and duct tape
whereas the prequels it was much more
sleek and refined because that was a
different era of the galaxy was a
different period in history now I don't
like the prequels particularly and I
absolutely prefer the original trilogy
of Star Wars but it is important that
they visually look and feel different
from each other because otherwise you
homogenized the entire timeline of the
world you've created and that's what
retaining David Yates as the director
does because this far removed from the
part of the Wizarding World that we are
familiar with should not look and feel
freakin identical to the one we already
know it's like 70 year difference and
nothing has changed and I understand the
Wizarding World supposed to be
anachronistic because they don't have an
advancing technology there isn't a
reason for them to change as much but
the overall vibe and feel of the world
should not be the same thing now I know
that part of it is they are building up
to Grindelwald much in the same way that
the Harry Potter franchise was building
up to the return of Voldemort which is
kind of the other problem this thing
really goes off the rails when it is
dealing with or setting up the
Grindelwald story especially because it
is completely and totally detached from
what we're actually here for it is
detached from Newt it's detached from
the fantastic beasts everything to do
with grim the vault and what is the guy
who's pretending of spoilers who cares
the guy who he's pretending to be graves
played by Colin Farrell and credence and
all of that none of that actually feeds
into or or impacts Newt storing the
story of him and Jacob try to find these
beasts again at all it is sheer frigging
coincidence that these two stories
connect
that weakens them by their nature and it
makes the entire Grindelwald subplot all
the more crammed in and also especially
when you think about it alright we'll
just jump to the end and the reveal of
Grave says Grindelwald my original
criticism of that is you can't replace
the character that we've been invested
in with the guy we've never frickin seen
before I expect that to have any impact
I'm actually going to amend that
criticism it doesn't bother me as much
anymore why cuz he actually can't get
invested in graves Colin Farrell he can
be a very good actor he can be excellent
in things however he is one of those
actors who can't fake it if he's not
invested in he's there for the paycheck
you can tell in his performance he's not
able to bring a sense of what he does
when he's really trying if he's just
there for the Paycheck and this really
feels like a paycheck job for him and it
doesn't help that the character is very
thinly written is basically generic
somewhat questionable evil ish guy we
know nothing about graves and we know
even less about grin the ball ran the
ball literally his name shows up in
opening credits sequence on the
newspapers he gets mentioned once in the
film in the body of the film and then he
shows up at the very end this none of
this has anything to do with the
narrative actually being told in this
film which makes it the most clunky kind
of franchise building none of it is
there for the sake of the story being
told or the journey of the characters
that we are watching it is there for no
purpose other than to set up the next
series of films and it is painfully
obvious that that is the case and it's
just clunky it is clunky and poorly
integrating you can feel how shoved in
all this stuff is because the the beast
story is done when they capture the last
one but then we have to deal with
credence and the obscurus and I'm going
to stick to my criticism of that which
is the the film tries to pull a gotcha
by going oh you thought the obscurus was
this little girl but it's actually
Creedence except it doesn't play fair
because it doesn't obey the rules that
it itself set out the film sets out very
explicitly obscure is's don't live past
ten credence on how old he's supposed to
be but Ezra Miller is very clearly in
his twenty so he has doubled that and
that is so far out of the age range of
how long these things are supposed to
live that it's not fair to go oh we got
it's really him because the rules you
told us eliminate him so that doesn't
make it a clever trick that you had this
this thing under our noses and whoop we
didn't nose like no you cheated you told
us rules that didn't actually apply and
weren't the case so it doesn't work as a
twist aside from the fact that the
entire concept of the obscurest and I
didn't even think of this before
doesn't that mean Harry should be an
obscurus and also the timeline doesn't
make any sense either if you're saying
they don't live to the age of 10 because
Harry didn't know he had magical
abilities until 11 when he got his
Hogwarts letter and he was absolutely
someone who was trying I mean he didn't
know what was going on but he was
fighting and trying to repress the weird
stuff that went on around him why wasn't
he an obscure EES and how the heck
doesn't kill people by the time they're
10 if they don't start magical education
until they're 11 how does this world
work in that case that they have to be
nurtured into this stuff well before
they're actually sat down and formally
educated on it the rules set up for the
obscurus actually become a major plot
hole in the Wizarding World as a whole
and then they break those rules anyway
to try and give us a snap reveal of oh
you didn't realize it was him like I
don't care you cheated I also really
don't like the version of the Wizarding
World we get in here now I will grant it
does not inherently taint the Wizarding
World that we saw in the other films cuz
this is America that was Britain there's
enough of a distance that if I decide I
don't like this Wizarding World it
doesn't make me suddenly not like the
Harry Potter and the Hogwarts Wizarding
World which is good because I don't like
this was a ding world it is dark it is
dirty it is not it is it's just
unpleasant
the only whimsy is the creatures and the
creatures aren't even supposed to be
there they're being rounded up because
they're a problem
the actual world that we see is dark and
depressing and oppressive and not fun
and that's a that's another problem
because the reason we cared about
Voldemort threatening the Wizarding
World in the Harry Potter series proper
is because we grew to love this world
this world
was something wonderful magical and
amazing and we wanted it to survive here
the world that I'm shown of The
Wizarding World in America doesn't feel
like anything that's worth saving
because yes okay it's grinev all
pretending to be somebody else
but graves on apparently on the
authority that this what the the
American version of the ministry is I
can't even think of the name of it now
and I'm not gonna look it up he has the
authority to him on a dime sending
someone to death and then send them off
to have them do have that done even if
you make the argument he's only doing
that because he's actually growing the
bald in disguise someone in his position
clearly has the authority to do it cuz
people listen to him and they go and
they go to to do this that screwed up
that's not a world worth saving that's a
world that is friggin screwed up from
the ground up you need to completely
tear this system down and start over
this is wrong which means when you
introduce him when you introduce the
idea of Grindelwald is going to tear all
this apart I'm like good I mean not
really Grindelwald is a worse thing he'd
be replacing what's bad with something
worse but I'm not invested in saving
this vision of the Wizarding World which
again I think is exacerbated by David
Yates his visual palette and how dark
and drab it is and just how unappealing
it is it also doesn't help some of the
little tiny touches that make certain
things that were always a little e in
the Harry Potter universe a little bit
worse so like the house elves are kind
of a weird odd thing in terms of this
because they're basically a slave race
but most of them are okay with that
it's a little weird if you actually
start thinking about it for too long and
it's made worse here when they go to
that club and there's you know there's
what looks very clearly like a house elf
except she's darker skin singing jazz so
they're now very explicitly linking
house at least in America linking house
elves to the black experience of the
1920s of underground jazz clubs of the
of that kind of repression which just
ties them all the more to the whole
slavery allegory and I don't think they
thought through the implications of what
that actually says in terms of the fact
that we leap forward to Harry Potter and
these people are still effectively
sleigh
I think they just thought the image of
an elf singing jazz was cool and they
did not think through the implications
of that very well at all which is I mean
I was gonna say it's not a comment for
this series it's not uncommon for
fantasy and sci-fi in general they think
of something like oh and we'll have it
be this but then they don't follow
through like Oh what does that say about
the world that we've created
but that's a minor nitpick thing as far
as this thing goes and ultimately
there's about there's about an hour's
worth of a movie I really enjoy in here
and it is the movie about Newt coming
you know with his creatures he has to
get them again he's got Jacob with him
they meet Queenie and Tina's fine
but like that story that's a story I
enjoy that's the story I would happily
watch again unfortunately it has to
share roughly half its time in the
entirety of the climax with this other
story that not only do I not care about
I actively dislike not that it's a
horrible narrative but it doesn't do the
work it needs to do for me to care about
the story that it's telling again you
can't threaten a world that you haven't
gotten me invested in and you can't
automatically leach off the investment I
have in Hogwarts because 70 years
earlier different continent you've got
to get me invested in this side of the
Wizarding World and they don't so yeah
that's my thoughts on fantastic beasts
and where to find them
next up crimes of Grindelwald I this
one's gonna be tough because I have a
feeling I'm gonna have a hard time
thinking of anything to say that I
didn't already rant very angrily in my
original review with that but we'll see
but right now have you rewatched
fantastic beasts and where to find them
any times any time lately if you have
drop something down they come let's talk
about it even if you haven't you are
still entitled to drop your comments
down there and we'll talk about it do
all the stuff like subscribe help me out
there are links below for merch for my
patreon that super helpful and all those
wonderful things but if you don't want
to you don't have to because at the end
of the day folks you are the council I'm
just running meetings and until next
time this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]